well hello I see you found the groom  room  you're not a pink person  oh it must be in hell  the school for good and evil needs great  heroes and villains but what if we've  been dropped in the wrong school you  don't understand I'm supposed to be a  princess  look at me do I look like a witch  or there's been a mistake and we need to  go home immediately the good do not ruin  with evils  you seem to be in charge and I am in the  wrong school oh how stressful and  improbable  what if we didn't make a mistake what if  we dropped them in the wrong School  something very bad is going on I'm tired  of being pathetic little so fake I have  to get you out of here  I have it under control I don't think  you do  princess can't be friends with a witch  evil is controlling you  can hear me Sophie I'm your friend  no you're my nemesis